- [Instructor] We're
told that f of x is equal
to one over the square root of x plus one,
and what we want to figure out is what is
the second degree
Maclaurin polynomial of f?
And like always, pause this video
and see if you could have a go at it.
so let's remind ourselves what
a Maclaurin polynomial is,
a Maclaurin polynomial is
just a Taylor polynomial
centered at zero, so the
form of this second degree
Maclaurin polynomial,
and we just have to find
this Maclaurin expansion
until our second degree term,
it's going to look like this.
So p of x, I'm using p for polynomial,
it's going to be our f of zero
plus, and we could do
that as f of zero times x
to the zero power, well,
that's just f of zero.
F of zero plus f prime of zero x,
plus f prime prime of zero,
divided by, we could think of it
as two factorial, but
it's really just two,
we could think of this as
dividing by one factorial,
which is just one, this
dividing by zero factorial,
well that's just one again,
so we have f prime prime
of zero, the second derivative evaluated
zero divided by two, x squared.
Now if we wanted a higher
degree we could keep on going,
but remember, they're just
asking us for the second degree.
So this is the form that we're gonna need,
we're gonna have these three terms.
So let's see if we can evaluate
the function and its derivatives at zero.
So f of zero, f of zero
is equal to one over
the square root of zero plus one,
well that's one over
the square root of one,
the principle root of one,
which is positive one,
so that's just going to be equal to one.
So that right over there is equal to one.
Now let's evaluate f prime of x,
and then I'll evaluate f prime of zero.
F prime of x is equal to,
well, one over the square
root of x plus one,
this is the same thing as x plus one,
let me write it this way,
this is the same thing as,
actually let me write it down this way.
Another way of writing f of
x is this is the same thing
as x plus one to the negative one half.
And so if I'm thinking
the first derivative of f,
well, I could use the chain rule here,
the derivative of x plus
one with respect to x,
well, that's just going to be one,
and then I'll take the
derivative of this whole thing
with respect to x plus
one and I'll just use
the power rule there, this is
gonna be negative one half,
times x plus one, to the,
and I decrement the exponent,
negative three halves.
And so the first derivative
evaluated of zero
is just negative one half, times,
if this is zero, zero
plus one is just one,
one to the negative three halves,
one to the negative three half power,
well, that's just going to be one.
So this whole thing, f prime of zero
is just negative one half.
So that is this right over
here is negative one half.
And now let's figure out
the second derivative.
All right, let me do
this in this green color.
So the second derivative
with respect to x,
well I did the same thing again,
the derivative of x plus
one with respect to x,
that's just one, so I just have to take
the derivative of the whole thing
with respect to x plus one.
So I take my exponent, bring it out front,
negative three halves times one half,
times negative one half, is going to be
positive three fourths times x plus one,
and then I decrement the
exponent here by one,
or by two halves, so that's
gonna be negative five halves,
and so the second derivative
evaluated at zero,
well if this is equal to
zero you're gonna have
one to the negative five
halves which is just one,
times three fourths, is
gonna be three fourths.
So this part right over
here is three fourths.
And so you're gonna have
three fourths divided by two,
three fourths divided
by two is three eighths.
So our Taylor, I should say,
our Maclaurin polynomial,
our second degree Maclaurin polynomial,
p of x is going to be equal to,
and I'll do it in the same colors,
going to be equal to one,
plus, maybe I'll just
write it as minus one half,
minus one half x,
plus three eighths x squared,
and we are done, there you have it.
We have our second degree
Maclaurin polynomial of f,
which could be used to
provide an approximation
for our function, especially
if our x is near zero.